can you please share on your podcast
what the difference between lazy
delegation and decentralization is okay
so decentralized command is obviously
the one of the principles combat we have
in the book that we wrote and I have a
very simple definition that I've been
explaining to people decentralized
command it's everybody leads
that's what decentralized command is and
and obviously that means you want
everybody else to lead and so this
question is what's the difference
between being lazy and just delegating
everything and what's good
decentralization so lazy delegation
number one is delegating things that are
actually your job right because there's
there's some roles and responsibilities
that people have and if you take
something that is supposed to be your
job and you delegate it to somebody else
because you don't feel like doing it
then that's lazy if as a matter of fact
if you're delegating something that it's
something that you're delegating because
you don't want to do it then then that's
being lazy right if you're actually
delegating something because it's
something you don't want to do then
you're being lazy and and I'll tell you
it's actually a mindset to take on the
tasks of the things that you don't want
to do or that your team doesn't want to
do so this is like literally do you know
there's there's something that is hard
to do or that no one wants to do do that
thing and I give you an example we had
to we had to stand watch in Iraq on my
first deployment to Iraq we had to stand
watch on the prisoners that we would
capture so we come back we have to stand
watch on them so I made myself and my
assistant platoon commander I was a
platoon commander at the time I gave us
I assigned us the worst watch of the
night like the zero 300 in the morning
till zero 500 in the morning the watch
that nobody wants because it's in the
middle of your sleep pattern no one
wanted that watch
put us on that watch we took the worst
watch so I didn't delegate the hard
watch
I took the hard watch so there's an
example of the opposite of being lazy
you're taking on board the hard tasks
you know another one is when we would go
shooting and we'd get done shooting and
believe it or not even the SEAL Teams
you got to go pick up brass you gotta go
pick up brass off the ground all over
the desert all over the field all over
wherever you did a bunch of shooting and
it's pretty easy for the guy that's in
charge to have a meeting to attend to
when it's time to pick up brass but I
would always pick up brass you know I
would brass Legation the shell the shell
cases but it's a pain you know literally
at when you're at land warfare it takes
a couple days to pick up brass and
instead of like I said instead of having
to go back for a meeting
I'd go out there and you know jump in
there and and have the crap job like
everybody else are picking up brass so I
wouldn't delegate these things that's
being lazy when you delegate that and in
another thing I'll find is if somebody's
complaining of some one of my
subordinates is complaining to me about
having to do something I automatically
take it and I say oh oh echo it's a pain
for you to do this
cool what I'll do it and it has a good
psychological effect on right I mean
it's it's it's it's showing them that
like look man I'm here for you and if
it's too much for you I'll take it
and I've had people literally go no no
no I got ya cuz that's the instinct that
people have they go look man I got it
and that's what I would do if I
complained about something and then I
said didn't my boss said to me you know
what it's too much for you I'll take
care of it you're like no no so that's
all I'll tell you there's also a little
form of discipline in there a little
form discipline of taking on board tasks
and doing things that you know you don't
want to do yeah that's a way of
exercising some discipline in your life
and making things happen so that's the
kind of thing all those things that
that's like lazy delegation if you're
doing those kind of things where you're
getting rid of jobs you don't want
you're getting rid of jobs that you
should be doing
and getting rid of jobs that are a pain
or our monotonous or you think they're
below you so the opposite that is
decentralized command right this is
where you're letting other people do
what they're supposed to do it's when
you're letting people do things that
will help them grow
hmm does it help a person grow by
picking up brass I suppose there's a
little character building in there but
it's not gonna literally help them grow
so you don't need to delegate that task
does it help someone grow as a leader to
do the 0 300 and 500 watch on prisoners
no it's pain it's just it's just
unmitigated pain so it doesn't help
people grow so that that then then you
don't have to decentralize that but if
you got something's gonna let somebody
grow you let them do it if there's
something that allows you to stand back
and be the tactical genius and only
wrote about this in the book you know
then and thereby allowing me to have a
different perspective on something then
I should absolutely decentralize that
delegate so if if there was a mission
came up and we need to come up with a
plan I would tell you to plan it I'd be
like echo you come up with a plan on
this and then you'd go and plan it you'd
be all involved in it and you would lose
the elevation that I would have so when
I come back to look at your plan you say
here's the plan I go hey it looks good
except for these two points and you'd be
like man how did he see those points I'd
say it's because I had the altitude so
that's another time that decentralized
command it's a very helpful
decentralized command means letting
people make little mistakes and not
punishing them because of those mistakes
that's decentralized command if I just
hammer people and punish them when they
make a mistake they're not gonna want
any cake any chance it's not gonna want
to take any risk and they're not gonna
want to lead because I've been punitive
with my actions towards them now that
doesn't mean and I've seen this happen
that doesn't mean if I'm gonna let you
go plan a mission and I see you're
screwing it up I'm just gonna let you
have a catastrophic failure no I'm gonna
be like hey echo think about this over
here hey echo think about that over
there we're gonna get you dialed in I'm
gonna let give you some rope but I'm not
gonna let you hang yourself I'm actually
gonna give you enough rope to get the
job done and think on your own but if
you start looking like you're gonna hang
yourself I'm gonna stop you the other
thing about decentralized command that's
positive that's not just lazy delegation
is when you let your subordinates lead
so that you can focus upward outward and
forward so if if you have a mission if
we have a mission to accomplish and I
tell you to lead it that means you can
take care of that mission I can look
upward meaning up the chain of command
find out so going on outward meaning
what's the enemy doing and forward
meaning what's gonna happen in the
future and if I'm wrapped up in the in
the accomplishing of the task at hand
from a leadership position I can't do
any of those things I can't look out for
it I can't look out when I can't look
forward you gotta let people lead so
that they can become leaders and your
actual goal and this is where people get
intimidated is to to set them up so they
can take your job that's what you want
you want them to be able to take your
job and people get scared of that but
you can't be scared of that yeah what
was that quote there's a quote that
where where one guy was asking the other
guy or something like hey what happens
if we develop you know our workers and
then they leave us and he's like it's
better than not developing on yeah and
having them stay yeah yeah yeah that's a
good point
I mean that's me trashing that you were
during a quote yeah no that's that's
good and you definitely want to set your
people up you want to work yourself out
of a job and then you've got a lineage
you your other opportunities will come
because people will see that you develop
a team people see that you develop good
leaders and they're gonna say hey I want
you to come and do that at this higher
position and you're gonna get benefit
from that as well well